es gibt eine ganze Reihe von Leuten die
im Netz versuchen die künstliche
Intelligenz
missbrauchbar zu machen also für
irgendwelche lustigen oder gar nicht so
lustigen Scherze und hier sind wir
inzwischen tatsächlich mit der KI so
weit dass wir stimmen von Prominenten
von Politiker in den von allen möglichen
Menschen imitieren können das heißt man
lädt ein großen
stimm-archiv hoch das kann Podcast sein
das ist eine Person gesprochen hat oder
eine Rede diese gehalten hat und dann
kann die KI genau in dem Ductus dieser
prominenten Person eine Stimme erzeugen
mit Sachen die man selbst eingeht die
die nie gesagt hat und ganz ähnlich
funktioniert das im Zweifel auch mit
Filmen es ist noch qualitativ noch nicht
da wo man sagen würde um Gottes Willen
aber es ist ehrlich ist es schon sehr
leicht ist es da ähm es ist definitiv
erahnbar und wir reden ja von der
ständig verbesserten Version davon das
ist ahnbar dass wir in den nächsten Wahl
kämpfen in den Vereinigten Staaten ganz
besonders